um we obviously need to start talking
about some of the events that have
unfolded over the last week we've got a
new Chancellor what are you hoping to
see from him well look I think that we
are witnessing a horror story to be
honest it's like watching a film behind
your hands and every time you look
there's something worse happening
um and I think that we've got a real
problem on our hands Jeremy Hunt is not
the answer to what is happening here uh
Jeremy Hunt if you heard him yesterday
was talking about a second round of
austerity and I think what people will
not put up with after the 2008 financial
crash this country went through 10 years
of austerity 10 years of pain 10 years
of struggle workers and their families
and they did that because of the
financial crash we have another incident
that is not the fault of workers it's
not the fault of communities yet they
will be asked to pay the price so I
think we've got a real situation on our
hands and we really have to discuss now
as a country who is this economy for who
is the economy for and I think that
there needs to be a change in government
um do we also not need to discuss us
what on Earth can anyone whoever the
government is do to try and regain the
trust of the markets and to look at what
many people are predicting I think in
the papers today 72 billion pound black
hole in the public finances Jeremy Hunt
uh talking about looking at spending uh
as yes but also looking at tax Rises
isn't that just being realistic no
because it's choices and that's what I
think really people are beginning to
understand now this is all about choices
it's not about one woman who's put her
foot on the accelerator because I think
what we've just seen is a glimpse of our
future nobody has said they think her
direction of travel is wrong what
they've said is the way that she's done
it is wrong and that looks to be where
they want to take us but these are
choices that you make how can you have a
situation where you make a choice to
make sure that Bankers do not have the
caps on their bonus that's a choice that
we've made but nurses can't get a pay
rise so we need an entire look at the
economy as a whole we need to say who is
this economy for who is it working for
trickle down does not work we can see
that it doesn't work who is it working
for and we do now need a change of
government you say that we need a change
of government and Liz truss has sector
Chancellor she's u-turned on most of the
flagship policies in her budget she's
got a new Chancellor in place with a
very different economic strategy from
the last one do you think she can stay
in her job well I think she will because
she'll try to cling on she either will
or they'll try and replace her turkeys
aren't going to vote for Christmas so
whilst I think that there should be a
change in government I have to say I
don't think that there will be a change
in government and probably they'll be
Clinging On right to the very end and
that is why labor have a real
opportunity now and they need to take
that opportunity and there's clear blue
water opened up on the political Horizon
there's no doubt about that but this is
not a moment to play it safe this is not
a moment to say um okay well look
they're doing so badly we just have to
sit on the sidelines here this is the
moment to take uh this by the Scruff of
the neck to say this is what we need to
do to come out with solutions to these
problems and to really lay out what
Labor's stall is get some metal lay out
your stall and say what people should
vote for not just what they should vote
against because I guess if you look at
labor now the policies aren't that
different from the conservatives and
they're actually if you agree with the
papers they're actually saying the tax
cuts should go further than the
conceptors by the 1p cut to tax being
brought in before the list trust plan
that you know they agree with canceling
their eyes in National Insurance and
they what is the actual difference
between labor and the conservatives well
there is a difference because of course
obviously what labor will do is not
attack workers in the same way they'll
do different things but
um I don't think it is acceptable just
to sit on the sidelines and have just a
little bit of difference you can't get
in just because you're a little bit
better than the other lot what's that
isn't the way what specifically would
you like to see labor do now then well
I'd like labor to really come out
fighting really to say look we are on
the side of workers and communities and
what does that mean so for example
asking the country to take a national
pay cut there is already a party for the
business Lobby it's called the Tory
party they are the business Lobby party
and what we now need is to see the party
for workers and communities and they
come out very strongly and say look we
are the party for workers and
communities and this is what we would do
so for example a very simple thing is to
give the public sector workers their pay
rise that's a very simple thing that I
mean the thing about the economy Sophie
is there a choices
um so the Banker's choice is a choice to
give Bankers their bonuses back that are
unfettered and then to say to nurses you
need to pay a pay cut there are choices
that are made in the economy we want
labor to come out and make those choices
more starkly so people can see them and
have something to vote for as well as
something to vote against because that's
really important do you think Coast
armor his character he's quite safety
first I guess do you think it's been a
bit too timid why do you want to talk
about personalities because obviously
let's hope we move a bit away from
personality politics it's the policies
that are the so the policy is too timid
the policy is too timid and we need you
know what people need now is straight
talking they don't want people dancing
around their handbags they want straight
talking this is the situation we are in
um I think everyone has seen the
direction of travel of where the
conservative party are taking us because
whilst as I said they are moving in that
direction they're saying too fast
they're not saying the Direction's wrong
they're saying the directions correct
where that Direction takes us uh Jeremy
Hunt yesterday was filled with Dread
when I heard him yesterday uh say you
know that we have to tighten our belts
to say that people have to be prepared
for tough decisions to be made that is
code for workers and communities will
suffer that is what that's code for
remember Jeremy Hunt was the health
secretary who effectively has a long
history uh in in this regard and so
that's what that's code for and you've
had run-ins your unions have run into a
Jeremy hunter in the past during the
junior doctors strike and unite accused
her men of contemptuous Behavior well
look what I think is is Jeremy Hunt
actually when he was a health secretary
one of the core things that he did was
that he wanted the NHS to be part of the
American trade deal he wanted the NHS to
be in the American trade deal now I
don't know what his plans are for this
country as Chancellor but anything
towards privatizing the NHS or anything
that is going to make poor people poorer
that really is a difficulty I mean we've
had no indication that this government
is going to look into things like that
and but when it comes to um obviously
the thing that you're talking about an
awful lot is workers pay and where do
you think he will be on public set to
pay well I think he's already come out I
think I think one thing that will unite
the conservative party very quickly is
anti-trage Union legislation I think
they are saying there he says again
yesterday they're going to bring this
forward in terms of some of the answer
Trade union legislation look unions are
a Force for good we're not there with
some big red button in in general
secretary's offices that we press and
say everybody go out on strike that's
not how it works how strikes work is
there are people in workplaces who have
issues they are trying to get them
solved their employer says no and then
you see that their employer is earning
Millions if not billions of pounds in
profit not all employers but some
employers billions if not and billions
of pounds in profit and they're saying
to those workers take a pay cut and so
this government and I think AIDS and a
bets that I think Jeremy Hunt will do
exactly the same and people be warned we
will be watching them carefully those
comments he made yesterday are is about
austerity they'll call it a different
word but what they mean is the pain yet
again will be taken by ordinary working
people and our communities uh now you
were saying that the strikes don't work
by unions pressing a big red button and
getting everyone to go on strike um
which of course I acknowledge
um I'm interested though in talk of
coordinated strike action now I've
spoken to the rmt in unison recently
Lynch said well we talk to each other it
will be silly for unions not to
coordinate their forces Christina McAfee
said well we're certainly getting close
to a coordinated strike are we getting
close to a coordinator strike well yes I
mean I've said uh yesterday that I think
there could be up to a million people on
strike um very very soon I mean what
we're seeing and I think we just have to
take this back as to why people go on
strike is that they can put all the
anti-trade union legislation in they
want they can pretend that it's Union
Barons pressing big red buttons this is
about anger anger in workplaces within
the public sector and in the private
sector so of course if I have the same
decision maker an employer that's the
same decision maker where members are in
another Union also of course we will
come together and we'll talk about how
we can get the best pay for workers this
is about winning money back into workers
Pockets so unite has had 450 disputes in
less than a year we've won over 200
million pounds back in to those workers
pockets and I unashamedly will do
everything I can to fight for workers
because they need someone in their
corner
when is a coordination Striker general
strike well I'm airspace it's just
depending on words I mean for me this is
about issues that happen in a workplace
um those workers are trying to get
themselves nobody wants to have a strike
or nobody wants to have a general strike
but you've got to see that this is pure
anger that's happening and if there are
a number of strikes happening at the
same time people can call it what they
like quite frankly my job is to win for
those workers so if there are issues
where employers have unfettered profits
they are not giving some of that back to
the workers they're not getting their
piece of the pie then unions will do
everything in our power to make sure
that we get those workers a good deal so
we could be seeing General Stripes this
winter well you could see multiple
strikes this winter but what people call
it is really up to them but there will
be multiple strikes I know in my own
Millions there's been 450 strikes in
less than a year 90 000 unite members
have been out on strike 200 million
pounds have been won back in the pockets
of those workers that is the job of
trade Unions that's what we should be
doing and that's what we're doing more
and more of so I can see that that will
escalate the thing is to solve these
strikes so safely it's not about strikes
for strike's sakes the government needs
to look at how are they going to stop
saying that this country should take a
national paper that's what they're
saying it's almost like an abhorrence
now to ask for a pay rise that they
shouldn't be saying we should take a
national pay cut and allow us to get on
with our jobs stop trying to stop us and
let's get more money in people's pockets
um just finally
um you of course are the leading Union
in the health sector lots of people will
be quite concerned about the idea of
doctors and nurses going on strike and
the impact that could have on patients
and Healthcare
um are we looking at a strike in the NHS
is that going to happen do you think
well look I think we are looking at this
being a very um real option that is now
being looked at um it's not saying it's
taken lightly and but I do think I feel
quite embarrassed actually that we are
in a situation in our country where
these people went out and I know it said
a lot about these workers going out in
the pandemic and it's almost become
white noise but it's absolutely true
we've forgotten what happened there they
went out when everybody else was in
their homes all these key workers
whether it's the NHS or public sector
workers across the board and they took
risks they didn't know what was out
there they've come back and told you're
going to take a pay cut at the same time
they've told Bankers you can have a pay
rise there is something drastically
wrong with our economy if we allow that
to happen Okay thank you very much
fascinated to talk and thank you for
coming to the studio today thank you
very much